ah oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
sa voix de christina ça va être h et on
s'aime beaucoup tous les deux ma vie
c'est une star d'amour depuis très
longtemps je sais chaque fois ravi
d'être l'âge c'est toujours la bienvenue
j'ai déjà plus où les content d'être
venu si dans quand on s'aime c'est vrai
on sait pas gratuitement comme ça
gratuitement si je suis pris mon coeur
est pris mais ici il était libre je
foncerai comme un gant et c'était sûr et
bien c'est christina vous dit il peut se
passer quelque chose
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être vous
libérer comme un tati dès 20h
[Applaudissements]
ouah
ça c'est le style c'est ce qui se fait
dans la journée à ouidah mauvais parent
mauvais pas mauvais par mauvais écoute
le kaki c'est très bien ça nous va bien
je pense que tu as bien dessiner un
avenir aujourd'hui je pense comme moi je
mettrais un jeu m haies en 7
[Musique]
moi je trouve que bonds a de toute façon
là nous sommes dans les classiques à
jean chemise blanche veste noir
chaussures bien cirées
mais il manque un peu de jeu c'est pour
discuter touche peut-être un peu trop
tard ou tenu également de nature n est
pas très moderne j'aurais fait un
rafraîchissement niveau coiffure
ouais voyez le jean est bonne on attend
un peu plus un peu mais qui peut-être un
peu plus brut n'ont pas toujours eu est
terminée
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
jeudi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui où
[Musique]
et
à
[Applaudissements]
alors je voulu révéler n'essaie de ses
gonds je voudrais bien je suis leur a
apparemment elle aime pas que ta gueule
et ce qui se passe les chaussures les
colons a fait ouais en fait je vais même
pas où je vais même pas documenté et
plus rien à faire non j'ai même pas
commenter plus loin parce que les plus
gros fachos ne faut pas qu'il puisse
exister c'est l'école en couleurs
chaudes tu t'es venu de toi
[Musique]